joining us now the starting quarterback
for the dallas cowboys in his fourth nfl
season cowboys off to a three and two
start taking on the jets this weekend
and it's dak prescott giving us a few
minutes today dak how are you buddy
i'm doing well how are you doing
doing great i don't know how much you've
seen about this richard sherman baker
mayfield thing from last night at the
coin toss but i want to ask you has
there ever been anything that's happened
at the coin toss at midfield that has
gotten you extra lathered up for a
game no i can't tell i can't say it has
uh i don't think going back to high
school i've ever ever experienced
anything
well maybe it'll happen this weekend
when you go to metlife state to take on
the jets you know and we talk all the
time about
guys staying focused one week at a time
no matter who the opponent is what's
your role as a team leader and making
sure that your teammates dot the eyes
cross the t's do everything they're
supposed to do this weekend not pay
attention to the fact that the jets have
yet to win a game this year
yeah i mean
especially coming off a week like we did
you want to you want to put the flip the
page and you want to just
put the next performance on tape you
want to get back out there and play
again so for us it's important to focus
on each and every day and focus on the
process that it takes to get ready for a
game uh and we always say in our locker
room coach garrett always says it i mean
those guys on the other side of the of
the ball get paid to in their nfl
players and nfl coaches so
we're not paying attention to those guys
records you know that's a good team we
got to focus on what we what we've got
to do to become a better team right now
and that's our main focus as we move
forward and get ready for this matchup
you mentioned coach garrett he was a
little feisty on sunday spiking the red
flag dropping the f-bomb drawing a
15-yard penalty that seems out of
character for him
i mean
coach garrett's a passionate guy he's
passionate about about the game and he's
passionate about his team uh and that's
that's something that we we all we all
as players support uh we're gonna back
up our coach up uh any time like that
you've now got a former teammate in
kellen moore who is your offensive
coordinator what's that like having a
guy that you used to you know put on the
pads next to who's now running the
offense and you're answering to him
basically
i mean we've got a great relationship uh
kellen somebody that i've always looked
up to
when you look at the game from from
knowing the scheme standpoint uh he's
somewhat of a genius and when kellen was
a teammate we're we're drawing up plays
and we're trying to get trick plays into
coach linehan so
now to see him him make that step and
become nothing's coordinator it's
awesome i support him he's doing a great
job but we have a great relationship
and it's a fun offense to be a part of
does he ever say to you you know if i
hadn't broken my leg back in 2016 you
wouldn't have started as a rookie
no we don't bring that up i mean that
was a bad injury for him so no we don't
bring that one up
what's the biggest difference now that
he's running the offense compared to
what it was last year
yeah i mean just addressing our offense
up when he does a great job of is still
getting
um our players and our key players the
ball where they're most comfortable uh
with it and getting them in space and
allowing them to make plays
uh but um so in doing that um just
dressing up you know motions here
changing up the splits changing up the
looks and the formations um but and he
just does a great job with that
what letter grade would you give the
entire team based on the first five
weeks of the season
i'm not into the uh into the degrading
standpoint from that uh we just have to
focus on moving forward right now uh we
have a really really good team we have a
lot of confidence in this team we have a
lot of confidence in the players and
what we can do uh so we're just gonna
come in and hold each other accountable
put a great week of practice
in the books and move forward and worry
about getting a win on sunday we just
know our best balls ahead of us
what more deck do you personally have to
do to get the offense to where you think
it needs to be
yeah just focus on the details of the
whole offense um not with just within my
game but just with the whole offense uh
taking the little things and focusing
those because those little things uh
come back and can beat you or hurt you
uh when you're playing these good teams
and when you're playing games that
matter so
for me it's just going to be about being
the general of that and making sure that
we're focusing on the small things and
the details and the nuances of our
offense and i know the big plays and
everything will come
you referred to kellen moore earlier as
a genius give me a specific example of
something he's done or said that's
caused you to say wow this guy's got it
yeah i mean he's got a good timing a
good timing with his plays
the way he sees the defense the way he
studies
the opponent's coordinator and the
things that they're doing um there's
been a few times whether it's at
practice or maybe just in a game i'm
thinking of a certain play uh because
we've discussed we've discussed it or
whatever and we've discussed a certain
situation and boom he calls it and it
leads to a touchdown so there's a lot of
examples but it's just his timing the
way he sees the game
when you are missing offensive linemen
like tyron smith going into last week's
game lyle collins during the game how
does that affect your role and your job
on a play-in and play out basis
yeah you know i mean it really can't and
that's the tough part that's the tough
part about our job and tough part about
football is you can't allow
something like that bother you or get it
with your mind uh but what allows
our offense and allows me to have that
trust is we we've got some good guys
that that can play we've got some good
guys that are are playing
uh in place of tyron smith and lyle
collins so if you go back and look at it
uh just knowing about trusting those
guys they're going to do whatever it
takes to get the job done cam flim is a
fighter i trust you many day of the week
on my backside and we had a couple we
had a good young briggy come in
on the right side and brandon knight who
pointed tell off on the back end of it
so just focus on
just making sure those guys are
confident in themselves and knowing that
hey
i'm not worried about it i know you're
going to get the job done
jason whitton is back after one year in
broadcasting what's the biggest change
you've noticed in him
i had nothing changed nothing changed at
all i mean jason
approached pro on and off the field
somebody i've always
looked up to and watched everything that
he'd done he sets the standard so
when jason came back um it was great and
then i mean it was it was great for this
team
in the locker room on the field and then
outside of that what he just means to
guys and the leader he is
so i mean
it was great for us
now if i were to ask him that same
question about you how has dak prescott
changed in the year that you were gone
jason what and what do you think he
would say
yeah i'm not too sure maybe just a
little bit of
maybe being more vocal as a leader i
don't know i've always felt like i was
vocal
um
i don't know i've gotten better i want
to say in every aspect of the game i
mean i put a lot of time and focus in
doing that so i would hope you would say
that but we've got to ask him
well one way you've changed dak and this
is changing all the time you have more
and more off-field partnerships and
today it's directv now i've got a direct
tv hookup down in my barn i had the game
in 4k last thursday night i had the game
in 4k the thursday night before it is
awesome tell us what you have going on
with the directv 4k on thursday night
football
yeah you just said it so for the first
time ever select thursday night football
games are being broadcast on 4k hdr by
directv including this week's game and
then including as well on december 5th
when we play the bears so
what directv doing is doing to celebrate
that is i've teamed up with them and
we're offering fans a chance to win an
awesome 4k prize package
which includes a 4k tv and an assortment
of my d4k apparel and all fans have to
do is go to
d4kdaksweeps.com and choose which team
they think will win each select thursday
night football game and directv will
randomly choose a winner per select
thursday night football game for the
rest of the season
you know speaking about uh uh the cap
you know
cowboys high profile team contract
situation everybody's talking about it
how does it feel to be in a profession
where
your money is such a topic of public
conversation and scrutiny
yeah a lot of people ask me that um
you know it's it's tough everybody has
an opinion of it
so it's just something it just goes in
that same category as noise something
that i can't focus on
um i know that uh
i'm blessed to even be in this position
and be even talking about
these numbers uh so for me that's what
it's about and i'm just not letting
somebody else's opinion
um dictate what i do
i've heard guys like steven jones
suggest that there's actual value in
being the cowboys quarterback and that
value should be reflected in your
contract do you ever stop and think you
know what maybe it'd be better to be
playing for a team that wasn't
constantly in the spotlight that wasn't
constantly the focus of discussion and
scrutiny i could just go about my job
going about my business
you know i'm so thankful to be the
quarterback of the dallas cowboys um
just the platform that it gives me um
with it with all the things that that
may not seem pretty that come with it
there's so many more great things
that go on top of that that
uh
that outweigh that so uh for me uh to be
in this position to be able to reach as
many people as uh that i can and tell
them my story maybe inspire them um and
then work with a lot of great
sponsorships like directv and play with
the teammates that i do nothing compares
to that
you know jerry and steven have talked
from time to time about speaking
directly to players to try to work out a
contract dez bryant's got a great story
about the time jerry tried to do it with
him has that happened have they tried to
talk to you directly to get them to
to get you to see their side of it and
get this done
i mean contract talks uh
that i trust my team to do that i've got
a great agent um and a great team that
that will do a good job of of
negotiating that so for me right now
it's about focusing on my team focusing
on new york jets um i can't give any of
that stuff focus right now uh it'll just
distract me from what what really
matters and that's i'm trying to get a
win on sunday
all right dak well hey buddy all the
best as you continue forward in the
season we look forward to seeing you on
sunday night football coming up in a
couple of weeks i know you got to take
them one at a time but i'm looking
forward to eagles cowboys in week seven
we look forward to seeing you on that
and every game you play this year thanks
for some of your time and all the best
down the road
yeah thank you mike thanks for having me
on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports